let's go foraging for birch zap birch
trees have this lovely silvery bark to
help you identify them
once you've found a suitable birch tree
you're going to want to use some
sacateurs or a knife to cut about
halfway down one of the branches check
that the birch sap is flowing and then
you can attach your container
the sap should steadily drip for quite a
long while this was only after five
minutes but i left this overnight and as
i came back the next day it was half
full
once you're happy with the amount you
can take your container off the branch
and give it a taste test
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
this is the magpie ink cap mushroom and
it is a fascinating little find
so the ink cap mushroom family do a very
interesting thing called deliques
and that means that as it gets older the
cap splays out and starts to almost melt
and this liquid that it produces can be
used as a viable ink source
this is what it looks like as it starts
to melt all you need to do is leave the
cap and there you've got it you have ink
let's go foraging for velvet shank
mushrooms
also known as enoki mushrooms this
stunning specimen grows on dead or dying
branches
often found in deciduous woodland the
bright orange cap is hard to miss
to identify this mushroom it wants to
have a bright orange cap and the gills
want to be white fading to brown in age
the stipe is velvety hence the name and
it goes from a dark brown at the base to
a lighter color near the gills
their most identifying feature is this
sticky cap that happens often after rain
the spore print will be a brilliant
white color and it's very stunning if
you happen to do one
[Music]
[Music]
you